[Musique]
l'aventure commence au coeur de la
Sologne au centre équinatures
le château de Cheverny aujourd'hui le
château de Villesavin demain et le
château de Chambord dimanche
à l'heure du café on fait les
présentations
Stéphanie moi je viens de la Marne
j'ai monté pendant 15 ans en club j'ai
fait un peu de compétition et puis je
fais de la rando depuis 5 ans
passionné d'équitation depuis que je
suis toute petite et c'est nos toutes
premières randonnée donc pour nous c'est
une nouveauté
oui
attribue les chevaux au 9 cavaliers
venus des quatre coins de France
on sent la température on s'approche
voilà un petit bisou et puis
et puis ça se passe bien
c'est déjà au fractif comme ça voilà on
peut ensuite c'est des petites caresses
comme ça un petit peu progressivement un
petit peu partout j'aime bien les
toucher un petit peu partout
une passion commune et des questions
plein la tête mais un peu excité on se
demande quel cheval on va monter est-ce
qu'il va pas trop nous emmener
aller trop vite ou
est-ce qu'on va pas s'embêter non plus
parce que ça va être trop pépère voilà
on se pose et est-ce que le groupe va
être sympa
[Musique]
le temps de dire au revoir et la petite
troupe serpente déjà à travers la
Sologne véritable labyrinthe de chemin
privé et public
j'ai une super application qui s'appelle
ifigénie et sur laquelle en fait chez
tous mes fonds de quartier GN les photos
satellites et les plans du cadastre donc
en utilisant la superposition et bien je
peux savoir si un chemin il est autorisé
ou pas ça me permet de visualiser ça
à 14 ans Diane remonte à cheval après
une pause plutôt séduite par le concept
plus de ton environnement parce que tu
regardes partout
tu profites de ton cheval tu apprends
bien à le connaître tu m'aimes on fait
quand même du galop entre deux
les cavaliers entre dans les 2000
hectares du domaine de Cheverny
là vous allez voir pendant votre visite
dans le château il y a tout un équipage
il y a une meute de chien de chasse à
l'intérieur
en 2004 ken a été sacré champion du
monde de trek les techniques de
randonnée équestre en compétition mais
pour lui aujourd'hui l'essentiel est
ailleurs le côté partage le côté émet
l'humain je pense que ça fait partie de
moi dès le départ et et ça nous nourrit
le château
après le pique-nique nos cavaliers n'ont
que quelques minutes de marche pour se
retrouver devant le château de Cheverny
donc bienvenue à Cheverny vous êtes venu
à cheval c'est très bien c'est une
quelque chose qui est important pour
nous vous avez vu qu'on met en place
des parkings vélo des bornes électriques
dans le village enfin tout pour vraiment
un slow tourisme
on est descendu de cheval on arrive au
château on ne change pas et puis on
repartir à cheval et c'est très agréable
le château de Cheverny un contournable
des randonnées de Ken
ce n'est peut-être pas forcément le plus
joli au niveau de l'extérieur mais entre
les jardins et l'intérieur c'est
vraiment un des favoris des cavaliers
notre groupe a repris le chemin des
écuries avec l'odeur des chevaux qui
masque celle des hommes les cavaliers
sont des privilégiés c'est pour ça que
pendant le brame on randonne à cheval
pendant le bras mais on arrive à voir
les animaux en combat au milieu des
plaines alors que des piétons normaux
les frais bouger
[Musique]
avant d'entamer la deuxième journée de
randonnée Caroline livre ses premières
impressions
on passe beaucoup de temps avec nos
chevaux on passe pas une heure on passe
hier on a passé 6 heures à cheval et on
découvre la lenteur à cheval on prend
notre temps ce qu'on fait pas d'habitude
et justement en parlant avec les filles
est-ce qu'elle me disait c'est qu'elles
apprennent beaucoup de choses sur le
bien-être
le bien-être du cheval et c'est vrai
qu'on a pas toujours le temps de faire
ça quand on monte en carrière
on est reparti
faites attention sur votre droite il y a
un fossé
au programme la visite du château de
ville Savin que les cavaliers atteint
droit après trois heures de chevauchée à
travers les bois de Sologne mais aussi
les villages avec leur patrimoine
[Musique]
elle a une partie romaine la première
partie une partie de truc juste après en
fait
les chevaux considérés par le code de la
route comme des véhicules doivent
cohabiter avec les automobilistes
ici on a très souvent des gens très
agréables qui nous permettent de passer
mais des fois on a des bruits qui
veulent absolument nous doubler dans des
sur les ponts où là ça devient plus
compliqué
c'est un cheval que notre groupe arrive
au château de ville Savin dans le
Loir-et-Cher une jolie propriété
familiale où les cavaliers bénéficient
toujours d'un guide particulier et
plutôt acquis à leur cause
là pour se balader ils vont pas
forcément toujours beaucoup visités par
contre nous on sait quand il fait sa
petite balade dans le coin il s'arrête
ici donc voilà c'est plutôt sympa
une autre optique en 1840 à peu près et
qui fonctionnait en fait grâce à une
énorme chaudière à bois alors chaudière
alors moi j'aime bien visiter les
châteaux j'en visiterai peut-être pas un
tous les jours voilà mais si c'est
intéressant j'aime bien parce que les
vacances c'est aussi un peu de culture
et selon les générations la satisfaction
ne se situe pas toujours au même endroit
la récompense est toujours des après le
château qu'on fait on va on va continuer
à en donner donc c'est la récompense un
peu ce que nous deux on n'aime pas
forcément grandement les musées mais
quand on sait qu'on monte à cheval après
ça change tout bien sûr
la récompense pour tous c'est le
pique-nique juste devant le château il y
a eu des
je ne sais pas mais vous aviez des
muscles ce matin c'est sûr évidemment
c'est un autre à côté non mais comme
tout le monde le dit le cavalier c'est
que le cheval c'est ce qui ment pas
la convivialité c'est rapidement
installée dans le groupe et chacun
explique sa philosophie du voyage à
cheval c'est une façon d'être vraiment
complètement impliqué dans la nature la
première fois que je suis passé ordonnée
j'avais rien j'ai pas de portefeuille
j'avais pas de papier il y avait pas il
y avait pas de portable j'avais pas
d'argent là tu vois personne tu es pas
embêté par la radio la télé les
catastrophes les gens qui s'entretuent
sur le trottoir pour des âneries
là tu es complètement
c'est génial
[Musique]
les chevaux en chienne les trois allures
sont montrées de signes de fatigue pour
la randonnée il n'y a pas vraiment de
race particulière mais Ken privilégie le
franchementagne un cheval Suisse très
résistant
ils ont été testés dès l'âge de 3 ans
sur leur aptitude sur leur mental à bien
accepté tout ce que peut leur demander
l'humain et parfois on les a même
croisés avec des pur-sangs arabes pour
réussir à avoir un croisement un tout
petit peu plus dynamique puisque on
randonne
entre guillemets vite c'est à dire qu'on
a des terrains qui se prêtent à faire
des allures donc le franchement time de
temps en temps peut souffrir de de ce
rythme là et lorsqu'on croise avec du
pur-sang arabe on réussit à avoir des
chevaux qui acceptent mieux la vitesse
[Musique]
il est même pas tombé une fois à terre
les cavaliers doivent prendre soin de
leur cheval
non mais c'était une bonne journée ah
c'est super ensuite seulement ils
pourront se rafraîchir et écouter les
consignes pour la dernière étape qui les
conduira à Chambord
quand vous arrivez au château vous
commencerez votre visite par le toit
vous commencez par monter tout en haut
parce que vos jambes seront encore
chaudes à ce moment-là elle vous
permettront de monter tous les escaliers
alors qu'après vos jambes ne seront plus
aussi performants
tous les membres du groupe ont pratiqué
l'équitation en club hippique avant de
venir au tourisme équestre un phénomène
en progression ça marche pour tout le
monde
qui sont faites par la Fédération
française d'équitation qui le montre que
les cavaliers adultes qui commencent à
monter l'objectif c'est d'aller se
promener à cheval c'est pas d'aller
faire de la compétition c'est d'aller de
profiter d'un cheval en extérieur et de
moments de calme comme ça
pour aller à Chambord
en tout une centaine de kilomètres en
trois jours et une quinzaine d'heures en
sel il faut gérer l'effort physique
un petit peu fatigué
un petit donc je ne sais pas vers
l'année prochaine dans quelle forme je
suis mais
l'idée c'est de continuer le plus
longtemps possible parce que c'est
vraiment un truc que j'adore faire
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait une vraie
cohésion de groupe et ça c'est très très
agréable et l'autre chose c'est que
comme on garde nos chevaux plusieurs
jours on arrive à établir un lien avec
notre cheval et on est content de le
retrouver le lendemain matin pour le
passé une nouvelle journée avec vous
[Musique]
les cavaliers pénètre enfin dans le parc
de Chambord et c'est 5400 hectares de
forêt mais ils sont obligés de suivre un
chemin balisé et souvent relégué sur une
route embouteillée mais tous ont
l'esprit ailleurs
j'ai déjà visité Chambord mais là l'idée
d'y arriver à cheval ça rajoute une
autre dimension c'est à dire qu'en plus
voilà le cadre extraordinaire tu vas
entendre les bruits de sabot sur sur le
sol ça projette dans une autre époque tu
te retrouves au même au même niveau que
les seigneurs de l'époque et puis que tu
partes dans un dans un nuage d'un seul
coup comme ça tranquille
cinq siècles plus tard nos cavaliers
peuvent contempler ce chef-d'oeuvre de
la Renaissance à cheval comme le faisait
à l'époque François 1er un épilogue
royal à ses trois jours de randonnée
hors du temps en symbiose avec la nature
et les animaux
[Musique]